[Music]
in big up daddy news oh that's not dick
up that day like big that's all the
nasty to dig up daddy's bit submitted by
Sarita loves JK Oh
Serina I really know about that their
name Rita
yes we do
alright so Salvador Dali's body is being
exhumed for a paternity test
dang it whoa who's that even want to do
the clock or nothing called Jupe clock
oh okay I really like sir really [ __ ]
awesome this is sovereign territory his
art is done great yeah they look like
towards the end of his well oh that's
really him yeah Oh what do you think I
look like a selfie like you're just
going like this oh so are there is
something like claiming to be a kid to
get his money or some [ __ ] I feel like
that would be the only reason why did we
talk down maybe nothing much maybe mom
was dying like something I never told
you yeah she's a you know artistic dick
did melted yeah so there's this woman
named Maria from Spain Maria Otto square
yes she's saying that her mother was
working as a maid for a family who live
next door to solvers our dog of course
it's always the maid story oh man come
here at daddy or something your father's
table wide amazing oh man why do the
real maid will never look like the porno
maid I don't know where did the porno
mates come from right now I think I've
ever seen a porno me press you never see
all born amazed of the bad their outfits
are cool or arm or the [ __ ] arm the
feather dusters yeah yeah there it is
your zoom huh yes
okay got it I got it I got it yeah I
remember watching Beauty and the Beast
the cartoon and thinking like all men of
the maid wouldn't win those [ __ ] hard no
but when the when the duster turned into
the main of the answer ah she's hot and
when I watch the real-life one of I hope
they made her hot and she was [ __ ]
bomb oh yeah
yo straight up though did not think she
was black in the real and she was she
was she was a black wig yeah they made a
black it was all she said she threw me
off a little minibike where I really
would I don't know he's just saying he
didn't think the fella does it girl
cuz I always pictured it everything in
the cartoon I thought there should keep
it the way it was and so it was proud of
it oh look at that she thought yeah
though cuz I was not that friend you're
in distress then just lines the
live-action one Oh know what uh Emma
Watson yeah ah I don't know I
that's fine if that's when everyone was
mad because the Beast was like a skinny
like weird dude he looked better as the
Beast that he did the actual person I
feel bad he's not that bad I'm just I'm
saying she should have got John Cena or
something I thought I thought realized
these was going to be more jagged we do
August on was he at least good that is
really doing a great singer but that guy
is a really good actor uh that in that
movie wasn't that great for me honestly
Michael jy good belt on who all now do
do me like 650 still making movies off
yeah same movies still doing this with I
enjoyed beating the b-flat action I
didn't mind it I didn't like to singing
though because the auto tuner voice like
a mofo
yeah actually try to handle and know
what's going on here okay yeah so yeah
so Maria she went to court to try to see
it there's any way that she can prove
that she is biologically related to
Salvador Dali and so the judge recently
ruled that they will assume his body
because
belonging or any biological remains so
they're gonna take up his body to see if
he really is a daddy now you need an
enough evidence first that kind of
points in all directions here and then
okay this is the last resort or were
they like oh you think he's our dad
oh no I mean won't you drink go to the
corner I'm not way to find I'm not sure
how long this entire that court process
took but she did go to court so there
was it wasn't enough to make it happen
yeah like for what reason though you
know I'm saying like let's say he is the
dad then like what is it then she would
much it would legally be allowed to use
his name and he'd be entitled to part of
his estate which he donated to being
when he died in 1989 I know I feel so
disrespected I feel like man I wouldn't
just because you're connected by blood
it's not like you're queen or anything
like that which it only makes sense if
like like let's say you're royalty and
in all the world time he dies and no
one's next to claim the throne and it's
like oh then the birthright no I mean
she could just be doing it for peace of
mind
yeah my dad and then now it's proving
she's that cool I could die happy now
yeah but she don't get to get no money
at all maybe she doesn't her profession
change your guyses mine so she's a tarot
card reader does that nudge change my
mind a lot Ashley tells me she's a
[ __ ] her ass how come she can't read
some tarot cards and find out for
yourself
yeah so what happened when they dig him
up and it's like Salvador Dali in the
case of 83 year old Maria you are not
the father do what this is like okay
looks like we can put them back what's
[ __ ] busy did they charge her for it
because those are dancing around
dojo haha be dope if you came up
I think he I think she owes the money
for the Diggory and everything yeah if
it does for not that she is his daughter
should be his only child I never had any
kids have you guys ever had your tarot
cards read
no yeah I want to I have might even go
to a place or they came to you I was I
did at New Orleans and oh there's a lot
of magic there yeah not all good [ __ ]
so I'm good what was your experience
like me I won with a friend
it was during high school and then this
lady should just tell me that I'm going
to end I'm going to end up having a kid
with the darker skin guy that I was
seeing at that time so [ __ ] some
other guy [ __ ] yo ty cool so and so one
of them was like lighter skin you know
is darker skin she's like you're going
to end up having a kid with the darker
skin I'm like what and then tears that's
all she said that's it no gender telling
me some live stuff to that there was
like someone close to me that you have a
typical shirt or no one close to you
wants a bad done on to you Oh God Oh
father you have a substantial I have
some positives no I know dad where you
had a baby by the the dartisans yeah
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah no oh no I
mean I did my but cuz I I try to say
that I'm not superstitious or anything
but deep down inside I really am and I
do believe in that [ __ ] but I tried to I
want to do this but I can't I know it
like that so um I I was trying to tell
myself like no like this does not going
to come true whatever but in recurring
true and then years later I was ended up
working with some lady at the hospital
and then she claims that she can read
people's palm and she just grabbed my
hand story reading - Jo I don't I don't
believe in that so she says no come on
let me just it's just for fun and I'm
like okay fine
into a deep Tiffany yes interview
because I can't confront her and be like
no and in so Jana telling me Isaac's
going to grow up to be really handsome
and successful and then that oh no the
curse
oh I remember one else's Tara card
reader told me she said that the third
love of my life is going to be the one
that I married which is the truth so
life can do first one she darken do she
cheese I'm with ya
you need to just go back to this person
they know what they're talking about
yeah yeah number so vague to like the
way like the way that they tell you this
[ __ ] it's like anything to get you into
it it'll happen it'll be I got a
question though so we're you like no way
this is true I'm going to purposely keep
having unprotected sex a show you're not
going to keep I was just like like mad
that's not true they totally thought
about it until it happened in our
remember I'm like with the cars any
positive things people will the third
11-mile one the time I came in person or
that dude was like Peter 20 buzzing like
- imma get her busting in her and every
sounds attractive oh yeah
is it already busting her ah do I get to
bust in her ah well you have me yeah
yeah better way to say it then that's
not so inseminate you like a petri dish
oh oh and better than losing in her - it
is you're right jack you ate in my
cervix mmm poor common side not of the
grapes are like I want to make a baby no
way my favorite roles better you didn't
love it create life with me
classy classic but but it's not the same
thing we felt great for us inside you
doesn't imply I want to get you pregnant
that's what it was inside you
and I buy you a plan B yeah in fact here
I want lovingly I've never done your
future told you like yes actually in the
real part no way okay part of the year
are not really the previous comers in
June yeah um no but my mom I think I'm
sold somebody what do you guys
somebody's the story before but um my
mom when I win Thailand those lady that
would giving her massages and was and
was also a fortune telling and she like
massaging my mom and then she grabs my
wrist
she got my wrist and was like and was
like might know my whole wrist my hopes
is when they're talking about forearm
and then she grabbed my wrist yes she
grabs he grabs me and was like when
you're 15 you're going to get into a
huge car accident and then and I was
probably like ten at a time I remember
thinking it's been crazy I'm be famous
there's no when we regarded it you know
so yeah like I was no I was like ma I
very much grab any Asian atomic I don't
call it at 10 11 12 13 14
true I was like in my head I'm like
impossible only famous there's no way
and then I didn't realize until I was 17
I totaled a car went on 15 and and like
but nothing happened to me but and then
it wasn't until a couple years later
like holy [ __ ] that lead was right
that's what happened to me when I have
to think about it after it the whole
thing happened on Mike we should say
that it doesn't happen how come people
don't ever hope they call it fortunes
where they tell you bad things I don't
get that [ __ ] let me tell your fortune
you're gonna die all right future
tellers right teacher tell me that [ __ ]
I got [ __ ] magic dreams I could tell
oh yeah you do yeah he does I've got to
believe in my powers
yeah I just got to hone my abilities
good I don't need that [ __ ] I am that
[ __ ] I believe in I should expect it
with one of their dogs when they're
missing and it communicated to me I was
[ __ ] I caught one of our burglars and
it was an internal thing that was
happening
I figured out that one of my family
members were going bankrupt I think I
figured out something else oh I knew
that my dog was going to die
and oh yeah I'm pretty magical hey guys
would you think of that video I know you
loved it so make sure to hit that like
button to watch more videos check it out
up here
[Music]